Interaction is a welltrodden question
within the EDH community with raging
debates over how much is too much, how
little is too little, what types are the
best, and what types are the rudest.
I've thrown my hat in this ring before,
but what has struck me recently is how
many people seem to not really
understand interaction as a concept and
what it is accomplishing for any given
deck. As with many subjects, we as the
EDH community have created lots of
little myths about interaction and
removal. When I say myths, I don't mean
strictly untrue statements, but rather
kind of true things accepted as
undeniable fact or sometimes true things
overgeneralized to be always true. So, I
want to tackle some of these
misunderstandings and in the process
drill into the fundamentals of what
interaction does, why different decks
want it, and how best to use it. To
start with, let's talk about what's
worth considering alongside your removal
when deck building. I've occasionally
gotten some flak because I tend to have
a pretty wide scope of what I consider
interaction and removal. And I'll
sometimes organize my interaction suites
in ways that other people find
unintuitive. Graveyard exiling is a form
of removal. Bounce spells are a form of
removal. And defensive cards like
propaganda are a form of removal, though
the degree this label will fit will
depend on the deck. I think the reason
this rubs people wrong is because they
have a very specific idea of what
removal entails. Removal is when you
remove an opposing thing. And more
specific tools like defensive cards,
graveyard hate protection, and pinpoint
land destruction deserve to be placed in
an entirely different mental category,
their own boxes on a checklist. In some
decks, these things will warrant this
sort of separation. But in many others,
doing this is a waste of time at best,
and in the worst cases, actively
counterproductive to constructing a
functional deck. No, instead of this
sort of checklist approach, the best way
to think about interaction is as a
network of overlapping solutions to a
number of specific game states. Let's
say an opponent plays animate dead to
bring back an archon of cruelty. And
let's say this poses a problem to us.
How can we shut this down before they
start attacking us with it? Well, we
could destroy the archon of cruelty with
creature removal. We could destroy the
animate dead with enchantment removal.
We could counter the animate dead with a
counter spell. And we could use instant
speed graveyard hate to exile Archon of
Cruelty in response. There are some less
common approaches as well, but let's
stick with these four. In this case, all
four of these options would be ways of
removing this threat. Dealing with this
game state that I've decided is
problematic to us. I'll allow myself a
single cheeky comment here and point out
that for our purposes here, a braid is
not a removal spell and cremate is. For
another example, let's say our opponent
is playing a Crankco deck and is
starting to pop off. several goblins, a
couple sources of untapping, an anger in
the graveyard, the works. A piece of
instant speed creature removal could
deal with this so long as Cranko isn't
wearing a swift boots or something.
However, there are a number of less
absolute ways to slow down or survive
this sort of play. You could have a
soulister route out to allow your life
total to keep pace with the number of
goblins on board. Or you could have a
defensive card like ghostly prison
already in play to limit the number of
attackers. You could even have a Thalia
Heretic Cathar to have the goblins
entertains life total as punishment for
their token crimes. Now, just what point
am I trying to make here, you might ask?
Put simply, in EDH, problems are often
more complicated than one single problem
permanent that needs to be removed, and
even more complicated than just being
the occasional spooky board that needs
wiping. Single target removal and
generic board wipes can be the solution
to a lot of problems. And I'd never tell
you to avoid these cards, but they're
far from the only options available, and
a lot of times they won't be the most
efficient way to tackle a given problem.
Sources of graveyard exile are generally
extremely cheap per mana, as are stacks
cards, defensive permanence, and other
things that stick around to hinder
multiple opposing plays. As a result,
it's beneficial to get to know these
types of cards and the sorts of decks
and metagames where they could play the
role of more traditional removal better.
When newer players are being inducted
into the ways of the commander format,
discussions of interaction tend to
center card types as the thing to focus
on. You want a way to hit creatures, to
hit artifacts, to hit enchantments, and
so on. To be clear, I have no problem
with this. Card types are undoubtedly a
good thing to think about as a starting
point. However, as you get acquainted
with more common play patterns of decks
and which ones you tend to have a
problem with, it becomes much more
useful to focus on situations that need
to be remedied. Some decks won't care
about certain types of threats as much.
A go wide tokens stack isn't going to be
as spooky if you're playing a thick
boarded mid-range deck. A pinging engine
isn't going to be as spooky if you're
playing a deck with a good amount of
life gain. Decks with more explosive
plays aren't going to be as spooky if
you're already packing a handful of hate
pieces, and so on. If you're playing a
deck with a focus on some defensive
cards, you're already going to be
somewhat shielded from a lot of plays
that involve large combat steps. And if
you're playing a deck that runs some
counter spells for protection, you're
already going to have some ways to nail
critical centerpiece cards or combos.
Likewise, an interaction suite that does
a good job of handling the threats of
one table might not do as good a job at
a different table. You need to know the
environment you're stepping into. To
clarify, if what I'm saying sounds
overwhelming, you shouldn't worry about
it too much. What I'm describing is what
takes place during a potentially
monthslong process of tuning and pruning
a deck, not necessarily what you should
be doing when you're first putting
together a deck. It's fine if you're
using templates or rough rules of thumb
to start out with, but as you get deeper
into tuning an individual deck, and as
you get more experienced as a deck
builder, it's generally good to move
away from deciding counts of different
cards using a simple template. There's
no way to know exactly how many removal
spells or overall interaction spells you
need because different forms of removal
will have overlap in the profile of what
they can answer, and different
interaction spells will have different
degrees and how much they hinder
opposing plays. Not to mention,
different decks run different amounts of
draw. Some of my decks will run
interaction counts in the teens, but
others might run 20some or even 30-some
cards that interact with the resources
of opponents in some way, excluding life
total. And excluding life total isn't
even necessarily a fair thing to do. I
don't know if you've ever watched how a
person with 14 life conducts themsel in
a commander game, but it's generally
very different than how somebody with 34
life conducts themsel. That 14 life
person will often find themselves
holding back on attacks and chump
blocking more often than they'd like,
and they're also going to be more
conservative in the sorts of spells they
play. Tapping out to draw a bunch of
cards or play some powerful amplifier
permanent is perfectly common place for
somebody at a higher life total, but
it's a terrifying proposition when
finding just a little bit of extra
damage could let an opponent swing
lethal. For that reason, having a higher
degree of life total pressure can often
allow for a bit smaller of a removal
count. All sorts of lateg game
permanence that would generally be good
candidates for removal become a lot less
of a concern if their controller is in
range of being rapidly focused down.
This is one reason why Magister Sphinx
is such a useful card in my Sharon slide
deck. The deck generally looks to build
toward a late game win. So having a way
to put an opponent on death's door if
they're pushing out of control a bit too
early is a sweet escape valve that takes
a bit of pressure off the deck's control
spells. Overall though, this life total
rule is generally going to be most
pertinent in aggro decks and especially
in Voltron decks, which typically look
to knock down players one at a time with
commander damage. Careful threat
assessment and a few swings with a big
commander can be worth countless pieces
of removal. And for the pieces of
removal that do exist in a deck, it can
be beneficial to have them be targeted
more towards the stages of a game that
are worth worrying about. Get rid of
some blockers. Kill something that can
let an opponent stabilize. remove a
bigger manador that might let an
opponent contest you. Flame slash isn't
going to be a great card in most slower
decks because it misses a whole lot of
stuff that you'll see in the later
stages of commander game, but that's not
super important if your most important
turns are going to be happening earlier.
Ultimately, all I'm trying to say here
is that different decks will utilize
removal for very different purposes. If
you're playing a creature-based
aggressive deck, you might want to focus
on options that can clear out blockers,
and you likely won't want much in the
way of conventional board wipes unless
you have ways to make them one-sided. If
you're playing a combo deck, you want to
focus your interaction on dealing with
obstacles to your combo and spending
removal on only the most imminent of
threats. In either of these cases, your
interaction will exist predominantly to
buy yourself time, and things opponents
have that require time on their end,
like draw or a mana engine, might not be
a concern to you at all. By contrast, if
you're playing a slower, more
controlling deck, you'll want to focus
more of your removal on knocking out
resource generation, such as card draw
engines, since not letting opponents get
ahead of you will be important in
winning in the long game. You also might
want to focus on interaction that
targets multiple things or which
accomplishes multiple tasks since those
tend to be more card efficient. These
cards do tend to cost more mana though,
which brings me to the final myth I want
to tackle. Let's talk about the
interaction staples of the format,
specifically when they should be played
or not played. Typically, the forms of
removal considered staples are the ones
that cost very little mana and hit a
limited range of targets, such as
Nature's Claim, or which cost a bit more
mana, but which hit a variety of
different targets, such as Generous
Gift. There are also a handful of board
wipes that end up heavily played because
they're just hands down the best thing
available in a given color. Now, am I
about to explain to you why these cards
are garbage that you need to rip out of
your deck? No. In fact, I'm about to
tell you exactly why these cards are
generally so good. Because I think a lot
of people have a tendency to accept that
these cards are always the best option
and treat it as dogma, a primordial and
unshakable feature of our world
alongside gravity and the rising of the
sun. And this does these cards a bit of
a disservice. Let's start with flexible
removal spells. Why are beast Within,
Chaos Warp, and Generous Gift good
cards? Right off the bat, let's make
something clear. One of these cards I'm
a lot less likely to play than the other
two. Can you guess which one? If you
said generous gift, you're correct. And
that's not an insult to the card itself.
It's functionally identical to Beast
Within after all, unless your opponent
is playing an elephant deck. No, I
merely say this to gesture at the fact
that Beast Within and Chaos Warp are
exceptional cards. They are hard removal
in colors that don't really have access
to much hard removal for creatures. And
in the case of Chaos Warp, in a color
that lacks enchantment removal on top of
that, there are several two-color
combinations in which these will be some
of the only removal for certain
permanent types you'll get. And that's
to say nothing of our monocolored
compatriots. So, you won't catch me
wasting my breath trying to get people
to take these out of their decks.
However, there are also two color
combinations where you'll have access to
lots of other options. Beast Within
won't feel as essential in a green black
deck since you'll have a number of other
reliable ways to remove creatures. And
as I alluded to earlier, any deck that
includes white is going to have ways to
deal with a variety of permanent types
already available. So, does that mean
these cards aren't worth playing in
color combinations where they're not in
some wholly unique niche? Not
necessarily. For one, these hit land, so
the importance of that can vary a lot
depending on the power level and matchup
you find yourself in. Secondly, if your
interaction suite is relatively narrow,
somewhere in the ballpark of 8 to 12
cards, there will be a lot of utility in
having each of those cards be as
flexible as possible. If I'm packing
nine pieces of interaction after my
first seven draws of the game, plus my
opening hand, I've on average seen
around 1 and a quart of these. If I'm
running 14 pieces of interaction, I've
seen around two instead. And if I'm
running 18 pieces of interaction, that
number is more than two and a half. If I
have a diverse interaction suite and I'm
seeing multiple pieces of interaction
pretty early into a game, there's a good
chance I'll have a way to deal with a
specific problem unfolding in front of
me. But if that average is lower,
running more of these versatile staples
will likely be a good idea. Personally,
I prefer to run a higher count of
interaction that's more carefully
integrated into what my deck is doing,
but there will be times when it makes
sense to run a lower count. Some decks
can threaten player kills or wins
faster, in which case removal won't be
as necessary. And other decks will be
tight on deck space and might struggle
to integrate removal into what they're
doing. Regardless, versatility of
removal is going to be one of the deck
building knobs that you can modulate.
And it's good to have an understanding
of when it's more important and when
it's less. Now, let's get to the
cheapest removal out there, your 0, 1,
and two mana options. These are powerful
for a very simple reason. They're just
mana efficient. If you're exiling a four
or five mana creature with a swords to
plow shares, that's going to be a
significant tempo advantage. This will
be most relevant in a fast proactive
deck, one that is mostly dialed in on
its own game plan and just needs little
bits of removal it can fit in around the
edges of turns in order to prevent
opponents from causing problems. The
most extreme cases of this are in CEDH.
here. Almost all instant speed
interaction is going to be zero to one
mana. And you'll sometimes see one mana
bounce spells played because it's just
that worthwhile to temporarily deal with
any non-land permanent for one mana.
Even if you're not playing some insane
combo deck trying to pop off on turn
four, lowcost removal options can still
feel quite good if you're willing to
play a lot of card draw. Because that's
the downside of these. They're single
target removal and some of the most
popular options actively give your
opponent a thing. So, by default, you're
going to be falling behind the table in
cards. If you're happy to go ham on card
draw in order to counteract this fact,
that's fine enough, but going for
removal that can hit more targets or
which provides some other benefit can
really help a deck to keep up in cards
and run smoothly, especially if there's
a lot of elements to fit into a deck
that will be taxing your deck space. If
you want a stronger sense of how to
densify a removal suite like this, I'd
recommend watching my removal video from
11 months ago, because that was a large
part of that video. I said earlier that
0 to2 mana removal is strong due to its
mana efficiency. And for some use cases,
that's actually kind of an
understatement. Specifically, anytime a
deck is holding up mana to use
interaction at instant speed, there is
effectively a mana cost associated with
that since if the interaction wasn't
needed, the mana goes unspent. This is
one reason why one mana options are
popular among the instant speed kill
spells. And it's also why lowcost
counter spells are especially highly
prioritized in EDH. And that's good and
fine. A deck with mostly sorcery speed
plays will want its counter spells as
cheaply costed as possible. But as with
lowcost removal, the issue comes when
players treat this preference as
unshakable dogma. Three mana counter
spells aren't inherently bad, nor are
four mana counter spells or five mana
counter spells. What matters is whether
you have other things to do with that
mana you hold up. The simplest version
of this is in something like a Drago
style control deck. My friend Hans has a
Lyla undefeated slickshot deck that
follows a simple premise. There's 20
blue red instance that draw cards and or
remove things. And once Yla is on board,
the deck plays very reactively, mostly
only casting plotted spells on its own
turn, a thing that doesn't require mana.
This allows it to play a suite of
exclusively high mana cost counter
spells, which can have backbreaking
upsides compared to their lowcost
counterparts. Aether Snatch fully yinks
an opposing spell. Sublime epiphany does
a whole bunch of stuff. and ending the
turn with time stop in response to a
critical main phase spell or ability can
be equal parts hilarious and
devastating. You might argue that this
is niche advice since most decks aren't
going to be playing at instant speed,
but it's nonetheless good to keep in
mind as an option. The other way to have
higher costed options make sense is by
having unspent mana roll over between
turns in some way. Storage lands or a
crewix adjacent commander might come to
mind here, but the most wellsupported
option for this is treasures. You can
spend treasures on counter spells if
they're needed, and if they aren't
needed, the treasures get to stick
around. Finally, there are also a
smaller number of counter spells with
built-in modality. I'm a big fan of
Mystic Confluence, and Cryptic Command
and Thas's Intervention are other cards
that also feel fine enough if played for
their other modes. This is also why
Three Steps Ahead has broken the three
mana counter spell mold and actually
seen decent levels of play. It can be a
three- mana counter spell, but if it's
not needed, it can also be a three- mana
filtering spell. and it can soak up
extra mana with decently mana efficient
results. There aren't a ton of amazing
modal counter spells at the moment, but
this is definitely an area that I'd keep
an eye on. And if we see more options
like this printed, I could see EDH
shifting toward higher costed counter
spells. As a final note, counter spells
are one of the rare types of card that
will consistently embody multiple roles
in decks. They're a form of removal in
the sense that they can nail pivotal
spells from opponents, and they're
useful for protection since they can
counter opposing interaction. When I'm
deck building, how I categorize them
will depend a lot on how important
protection is for my game plan. If I
expect to have critical plays my
opponents will be trying to answer, I'll
generally either put counter spells in
their own category or lump them into a
protection category along with some
other sorts of protection cards.
Sometimes I'll even throw recursion
spells into a protection category as
well if there are critical permanence to
protect, which can help with
conceptualizing a deck so long as you
keep in mind that different cards are
accomplishing the protection task in
different ways. On the other hand, if I
have less to protect and I expect my
counter spells to be mostly aimed at
stopping my opponent's plays, putting
them in their own category is less
helpful for understanding my deck and
I'm more likely to lump them in with the
other interaction in a deck. And that's
what this is about. How you categorize
your cards matters for being able to
understand your own deck and make sure
you're able to accomplish the different
tasks you want to accomplish. My Sharon
slide deck does use its seven counter
spells for protection sometimes, but I
keep these cards in the broader control
category because these cards are a bit
too messy in what they accomplish to put
into a standalone category. Three of
them are counter spells with cycling
that can be used as fuel for astral
slide. One also serves as a flickerable
removal engine. One of them has
transmute. And how am I even supposed to
categorize what nimble obstructionist
does? In this case, the interaction
suite of this deck is too convoluted and
multifaceted to be worth trying to make
more digestible. and I know any overhaul
of it is going to require a whole lot of
effort. Anyway, the one aspect of my
control suite I do differentiate with a
subcategory is the creatures with ETBs
since building flicker-based engines to
suppress opponents is a key part of the
deck. And if I click the category in
architect to select those cards, this
becomes evident. I have other decks I
could go into detail discussing the
interaction suites of and how I
categorize them, but that would pretty
well destroy the pacing of this video.
However, in preparation for Magic on
Vegas, I'm doing audits of a bunch of my
decks. And so, I'm releasing a bonus
segment of how the interaction suites of
each of my decks are looking and what
changes I'm looking to make before
Vegas. Some of these decks I haven't
visited a whole lot lately, so it's kind
of fun evaluating the decisions of my
past self. To access that, you can
either join my Patreon or my newly
launched YouTube membership. This video
will be in both places. With that said,
thanks for watching, and here's a
preview of that video. Like, on a
technical level, the interaction numbers
are super super high here. Like I have
like 20 discard spells, 11 cards I would
call removal for permanence. Um like
five graveyard hate cards plus a couple
others in other categories. So like in
theory we're packing a lot of ways to
involve ourselves with our opponents in
some way. So among these there are going
to be some like damage based creature
removal. I think there are four of
these. Uh four of them are going to be
targeted creature removal like fel the
profane. Uh, and then one enchantment
removal, which is going to be withering
torment, and three artifact removal.
There's some overlap in these
categories. Some of these do multiple,
but that's what's going on here. Um, I
think the weak point here would probably
be enchantment removal, particularly
given that there are a lot of
enchantments that are going to be
generating card advantage. So, not
having a way to deal with that seems
like a problem here. I'm also kind of
looking sideways at Bedvil right now,
honestly, because I'm running this
instead of Chaos Warp, and I'm
questioning why Chaos Warp isn't here to
deal with multiple permanent types. You
know, this is harder on the mana, hits
fewer permanent types. I like the Ratos
vibes. Love the the vibes here. Uh, you
know, I kind of I kind of like the the
mana cost as like a flavor thing as
well, but um yeah, this feels like a
weird inclusion. I don't know. I'll
probably find a way to fit Chaos Warp
into here because I think that really
probably belongs in here. I might look
for another piece of enchantment removal
as well, but I think getting up to two
will be good. Beyond that, I'm actually
pretty happy with this deck's uh removal
base. We've got kind of a lot of ways to
kill small creatures. So, we've got like
Fiery Confluence, Mizium Mortars. Uh got
the discard spell. What is
it? Let's play a game. Yeah, that one
can make kill small creatures, too. Um,
Carter can go to a whole bunch of
creatures and it's obviously stronger
against smaller cre small smaller
creatures and I think that's going to be
especially important because Malfagore
just doesn't handle tokens well. So, I
think having that, having a little bit
of blood artist stuff here and there,
that should help deal with the token
matchups, um, which I like a